[Applause]
despite a rotten economy a miserable
foreign policy and a terrible record of
deporting Hispanic immigrants and
raiding medical marijuana dispensaries
that are legal under state law Barack
Obama handily won a second term as
president and Democrats even picked up
seats in the US Senate here are three
reasons Mitt Romney and the Republicans
lost big in election 2012 and how they
might win future contests I so wish that
I had been able to fulfill your hopes to
lead the country in a different
direction back in the day Ronald Reagan
granted amnesty to millions of
immigrants and George W Bush pulled high
percentages of the Latino vote as
governor of Texas and President of the
United States Mitt Romney and the
party's palpable disdain for immigrants
Romney called for self deportation for
God's sake is not only grossly inhumane
and uh neck it's no way to speak to an
increasingly multi-ethnic and gloriously
mongrelized America I so wish that I had
been able to fulfill your hopes to lead
the country in a different direction
voters in Colorado in Washington State
have legalized marijuana a substance
Barack Obama once used heavily and now
arrest people in record numbers for
selling his medicine the GOP should take
the lead in ending the war on drugs of
life destroying money wasting
Constitution shredding tragedy that is
antithetical to limited government and
personal responsibility I so wish that I
had been able to fulfill your hopes to
lead the country in a different
direction
marriage equality initiatives one in
Maine Maryland Washington State and an
anti gay marriage amendment lost in
Minnesota Republican candidates
statements about rape and abortion
turned off voters concerned about
reproductive rights there's plenty of
room for serious disagreement on these
issues but it's clear that Americans
don't want these things controlled by
the
the GOP should look across the aisle to
the Libertarian Party candidate Gary
Johnson for pointers towards the future
the former governor of New Mexico won
over a million votes the lp's best
showing since 1980 Johnson success shows
that Americans are increasingly
interested in what the GOP has always
said it stood for but never delivered up
a government that stays out of the
boardroom and out of the bedroom for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]